[موسيقى]
مشهد تعجز الكلمات عن وصفه
جنود مدججون بالاسلحه يعتدون على سيدات
واطفال وشبان كل ذنبهم انهم يعتكفون داخل
المسجد الاقصى في الشهر الفضيل انتهاكات
جنود الاحتلال شملت كل اروقه المسجد
الاقصى
ضرب وتنكيل ورصاص وقنابل صوت رافقت هذه
المشاهد حمله اعتقالات بحق اكثر من 400
مصلل اغلبهم فتيا تم تكبيرهم وضربهم ومن
ثم نقلهم في حافلات الى مراكز التوقيف
والتحقيق قبل الافراج عن عشرات منهم في
ساعات الصباح بشرط الابعاد عن البلده
القديمه لمده اسبوع تم الاعتداء علينا في
وحشيه كوني انا كمسعف لما شاف للضابط تم
الاعتداء عليه في وحشيه وشلحني الفيست وتم
تصويري من قبلهم عسبه انه انا مخرب
اما هذا المشهد فهو ايضا لا يحتاج الى
كلمات لوصفه الاعتداء على مصلينا اثناء
تاديه الصلاه لكن المعتكفين ورجال الدين
اكدوا انهم سيواصلون الاعتكاف في المسجد
مهما كان حجم التنكيل
المسؤولين في الحكومه الجديده
الاسرائيليه المتطرفه هم انفسهم الذين
يطالبون باقتحامات الاقصى وهم الذين يحمون
المقتحمين نحن نحمل الحكومه القائمه
الاسرائيليه المسؤوليه الكامله عن المس
بالاقصى
لا القياده الفلسطينيه ودولا عربيه لاجراء
اتصالات عاجله خشيه انفجار الوضع مع اطلاق
فصائل المقاومه صواريخ من قطاع غزه بينما
اكدت الفصائل على اختلاف اطيافها ان القدس
والاقصى خط احمر وحذرت اسرائيل من مغبه
استغلال الاعياد اليهوديه والسماح
للمتطرفين بتفجير الوضع لم تكتفي قوات
الاحتلال بتقييد حركه الفلسطينيين
ومصادره حقوقهم بل ان التضييق عليهم
استهدف حتى حقهم في العباده وسط مخاوفه من
اقدام حكومه اليمين المتطرفه على ما هو
اسوا خلال الايام المقبله شوفوا البديري
الجزيره من امام المسجد الاقصى المبارك
القدس المحتله